ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA.
OUR QUE HAN.
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BURNER **** BATH.
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO CERVANTES CHAU
[inaudible] TEN DAVID CHIU.
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM DALY [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN FLORA.
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN.
GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GLORIA GONZALEZ IS GRAY.
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
CHOLERA KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LIMóN OWN
[inaudible]
LOW MAIENSCHEIN.
MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA.
MELENDEZ MULLIN MURATSUCHI
NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK
QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS RAMOS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO.
SALAS SANTIAGO.
SMITH [inaudible]
STONE.
TING VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON WEBER.
WICKS WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY. TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER.
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN.
THE REVEREND PATTY OSHITA RIVER
NOTION.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
I GREW UP SURROUNDED BY
GRAPEVINES.
THE VINES WERE IN OUR FAMILY FOR
TWO GENERATIONS.
MY DAD REMEMBERED HIS FATHER
FARMING WITH TWO MEALS NAMED
JACK AND KATE.
MY GRANDPARENTS CAME FROM JAPAN
IN THE EARLY NINETEEN HUNDREDS.
AND THE VINES THAT MY FATHER
TENDERLY CARED.
FOR ARE NOW OVER ONE HUNDRED
YEARS OLD.
HE ONCE TOLD ME THAT AS LONG AS
YOU TAKE CARE OF THEM THEY WILL
TAKE CARE OF YOU.
IT WAS IN THIS MONTH OF JUNE IN
TWO THOUSAND THREE WHEN WE LOST
MY MOM. TO ACUTE MYELOID
LEUKEMIA THAT MY DAD FINALLY
CLIMB DOWN FROM HIS TRACTOR AT
THE AGE OF EIGHTY TWO I REMEMBER
HIM SAYING THEN.
AS HE LOOKED OUT AT HIS VINCE
VINEYARD.
THESE VINES HAVE BEEN VERY GOOD
TO US THEY HAVE GIVEN US A GOOD
LIFE.
AS A YOUNG CHILD ARE RARELY SAW
HIM. FOR HE WAS UP AT FOUR AM
AND HE WOULD WORK AS LONG AS
THERE WAS DAYLIGHT IN EVEN AFTER
DINNER HE WOULD GO OUT TO
PREPARE HIS EQUIPMENT FOR THE
NEXT DAY.
ADD GREW GRAPES -- PEACHES AND
PLUMS. FOR FARMER THERE ARE NO
WEEKENDS OR HOLIDAYS FOR THE
FRUIT HAVE NO CONCEPT OF HAVING
DAYS OFF.
IN THE SUMMER MY YOUNGER SISTER
BROTHER AND I WORKED IN OUR
SMALL PACKING SHED.
BOXING PEACHES FOR DISTRIBUTION.
AS KIDS WE ALWAYS SEEM TO FIND A
WAY TO MAKE EVERYTHING INTO A
GAME.
WELL WORKING JUST EIGHT AM TO
FOUR PM GIVE ME A GLIMPSE INTO
JUST HOW HARD MY DAD WAS ALWAYS
WORKING.
THE VINES MAY HAVE GIVEN US A
GOOD LIFE.
BUT I KNOW THAT THIS COULD NOT
HAVE HAPPENED WITHOUT MY DAD'S
LIVING DEDICATION.
SACRIFICES AND HARD WORK.
WE ARE SO FORTUNATE TO STILL
HAVE MY DAD WHO WILL BE NINETY
SEVEN THIS YEAR.
I QUIETLY THANK HIM EVERY DAY.
HE WORKED SO VERY HARD SO THAT
HIS CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN
WOULD HAVE EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE A BETTER LIFE. TO CHOOSE
THE CAREERS.
JOBS WE WEEKENDS HOLIDAYS AND
VACATIONS.
IN OBSERVING FATHER'S DAY THIS
WEEKEND.
LET US REFLECT ON THE ON INDIAN
GET A GRANTED TO WE OWE TO OUR
DADS.
WE HAVE NURTURED OUR LIVES WITH
THEIR HARD WORK.
IN OFTEN UNSPOKEN LOVE AND
SUPPORT.
NUMBER MENDOZA WITH KINDNESS AND
GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOLEY AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER COLD.
CALLING SALUTE.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
OF THE NINE IS ABLE [inaudible]
YES.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
MEMBERS THERE WILL BE A
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS IN THE RULES
COMMITTEE ROOM AT THIS TIME A
COMMITTEE ROOM MEMBERS WE ARE IN
RECESS CENTER CALL OF THE
SPEAKER.
WE ARE IN RECESS MEMBERS UNDER
CALL THE SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A SPECIAL
AGAINST INTRODUCTION TODAY TODAY
WE HAVE WITH US GIRL SCOUT TROOP.
THREE THREE FOUR NINE SEVEN FROM
MY HOMETOWN OF AROUND THAT.
AND THEY'RE VISITING US HERE TO
COMPLETE THEIR IT'S YOUR WORLD
CHANGE IT LEADERSHIP JOURNEY SO
WE'D LIKE TO WELCOME THEM AND
CONGRATULATE THEM ON THIS
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
WE ARE BACK IN SESSION
[inaudible]
NO
.
WE ARE MOVING TO THE READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
MONDAY JUNE THIRD TWENTY
NINETEEN RECENTLY MET AT ONE PM
ON WRAL KEVIN MULLIN SPEAKER PRO
TEM THAT THIS IS ALL THEIR OWN
MOVES MISTER FLORES SECONDS AT
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE.
TODAY'S ABSENCES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL FOR ILLNESS
.
MEMBERS WHERE PROCEDURAL MOTIONS
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR MOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SPEND SEVERAL FORTY FOUR FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW SOME
MEMBERS RUBIO PATTERSON AND
HOLDING TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN
MEMBER TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE REFER
THE FOLLOWING BILLS COMMITTEE SB
EIGHTY SIX DORADO FROM THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
SB ONE EIGHTY TWO JACKSON FROM
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
TO THE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE AND THEN
BACK TO THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE.
SB TWO OH TWO WILL FROM THE
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND THEN
BACK TO THE AGRICULTURE
COMMITTEE SB TWO NINETY SEVEN
PAN FROM EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO
THE HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
AND BACK TO THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE S. BEFORE THIRTY ONE
WIRE FROM ELECTIONS AND
REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE SB FIVE THIRTY
FOUR BRADFORD FROM THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
AND THEN BACK TO THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE SB SIX SIXTY FOUR
ALLEN FROM ELECTIONS AND
REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE SB SIX NINETY
FIVE PORTANTINO FROM HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT A TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE IN SB.
SEVEN THIRTY SIX I'M BURKE FROM
THE JOBS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND THE ECONOMY
COMMITTEE TO THE ARTS
ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS TOURISM
INTERNET MEDIA COMMITTEE.
AND THEN BACK TO THE JOBS
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND ECONOMY
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER I MOVE TO SUSPEND
JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO A THE FONG
NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE TO HEAR SB FOUR SIXTY
NINE DODD TODAY UPON GERMAN
SESSION IN ROOM.
FOUR THREE SEVEN MR FLORA FOR
PURPOSE SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER WE WITH
OLD UNANIMOUS CONSENT ASK FOR
ROLL CALL VOTE.
MR FLORA IS WITHHOLDING MEMBERS
THIS IS.
A PROCEDURAL MOTION MISTER
CALDERON MOVES AND MR BONTA
SECONDS.
ON IN THE RULES SUSPENSION
MEMBERS AS A PROCEDURAL VOTE
TAKES.
FORTY ONE TAKES FORTY TODAY
TAKES FORTY TODAY THANK YOU
DOTSON.
CARPAL OF THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTE THIS IS PROCEDURAL.
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE MISTER FLORA AND NO.
ON THE RULES SUSPENSION MISTER
CALDERON AYE MR FLORA NO
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSER ALL.
I ABOUT ICE FIFTY ONE KNOWS NINE
THE RULES ARE SUSPENDED MISTER
CALDERON YOU AGAIN RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SPEND SEVERAL FIFTY SIX TO ALLOW
THE PREPARATIONS COMMITTEE TO
NOTICE SB. FOUR SIXTY NINE DODD
FOR A HEARING ON WEDNESDAY JUNE
NINETEENTH PENDING RE REFER --
FROM THE GOVERNMENT WORK
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
[inaudible]
SECOND READING.
COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT FOURTEEN WITH THE
MOMENT SENATE BILL TWENTY FOUR
WITH MOMENTS ONE FIFTY WITH THE
MEMONS FIVE EIGHTY SIX WITH THE
MOMENT AT THREE SIXTY SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS.
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS ON RECONSIDERATION ITEMS
SEVEN AND EIGHT WILL BE
CONTINUED
.
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SIX AB SEVENTY FOUR BY MR TANG.
COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY WILL SEVENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING AND
ACTUALLY TO THE STATE BUDGET TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BUDGET
BELL.
MISTER TECH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I
AM VERY PROUD TO PRESENT AB
SEVENTY FOUR OUR BUDGET BILL.
AS YOU ALL KNOW MEMBERS THE
BUDGET BILL IS THE CULMINATION
OF MONTHS OF WORK.
BLOOD MANY MANY HOURS OF
HEARINGS IN OUR SUBCOMMITTEES.
HOURS AND HOURS OF PUBLIC
COMMENT IN TESTIMONY TO REALLY
CRAFT THE STATE'S BUDGET.
IN THIS YEAR WE HAVE A BUDGET
THAT WE CAN ALL BE VERY PROUD OF
FIRST OF ALL IT'S A RESPONSIBLE
BUDGET.
WE'VE SET ASIDE NINETEEN POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IN RESERVES.
BECAUSE AS OUR ECONOMY HAS BEEN
DOING GREAT.
WE KNOW THAT AT SOME POINT SOON
A RECESSION WILL BE COMING AND
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
SAVING THAT MONEY FOR A RAINY
DAY.
WE ALSO PAID FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS.
INTO OUR PENSION FUNDS CAL STARS
IN CALPERS.
WE HEARD FROM SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
ACROSS THE STATE EXCUSE ME
ACROSS THE STATE IT HURT.
THAT THEY WERE HAVING CHALLENGES
AS WE HAVE.
IMPOSED HIGHER PENSION
OBLIGATIONS ON THEM.
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT ASSISTANCE REACHED CALPERS
AND CAL STIRS TO REALLY HELP
WITH OUR LONG TERM UNFUNDED
LIABILITIES.
WE INVEST IN YOUNG PEOPLE FIRST
AND FOREMOST.
WE ARE NOW AT A RECORD EIGHTY
ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN PROP
NINETY EIGHT K. THROUGH TWELVE
FIND.
THAT IS ALMOST DOUBLE THE AMOUNT
OF PROP NINETY EIGHT FUNDING
WHEN MY CLASS THE CLASS OF
TWENTY TWELVE ENTERED.
INTO THESE CHAMBERS.
WE HAVE ADDED TEN THOUSAND FOUR
DAY PRESCHOOL SLOTS. THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
KINDERGARTEN FACILITIES. TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR CHILD CARE
FACILITIES.
IN FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS WHICH AS A
WORKING PARENT I KNOW THAT I
COULDN'T BE HERE.
IN WORK EVERY DAY IF IT WASN'T
FOR THOSE AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
THE EVENTS BUT DOESN'T STOP
THERE BECAUSE FOR HIGHER ED.
WE WANTED TO FOCUS ON ENSURING
THAT THERE WERE MORE SLOTS
AVAILABLE FOR CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS.
SO FOR YOU SEE WE INVESTED IN
ALMOST FIVE THOUSAND MORE SLOTS.
FOR GRADUATING CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS.
IN CS YOU WE INVESTED IN OVER
TEN THOUSAND SLOTS.
BECAUSE I KNOW MEMBERS
ESPECIALLY THIS TIME OF YEAR WE
HERE AT THE GROCERY STORE WE
HEAR MORE OUT IN THE COMMUNITY
HOW HARD IT IS FOR CALIFORNIA'S
GRADUATED FROM HIGH SCHOOL. TO
GET INTO OUR CRITICAL UC AND CSU
UNIVERSITY SO WE'VE HEARD THEM
AND WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S MORE ROOM. FOR
CALIFORNIANS IN THOSE SCHOOLS.
BUT IT DOESN'T END THERE BECAUSE
WE HAVE TO INVEST IN
CALIFORNIA'S WITH A HARD TIME
[inaudible]
PAYING [inaudible]
FOR SCHOOL.
WE ADDED ELEVEN THOUSAND
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT SLOTS THAT
WAS CHAMPIONED BY TWO OF OUR
LEADERS FROM SACRAMENTO
RIVERSIDE THIS YEAR.TO REALLY
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE WHO CAN'T
AFFORD HIGHER EDUCATION REALLY
CANNOT ONLY AFFORD IT.
BACK GRADUATE WITHOUT ANY DOUBT.
WE ALSO CONTINUED.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LA SHIPPING
FOR FREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SO
NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE ONE YEAR
FREE WE DON'T HAVE TWO YEARS OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FREE.
BUT AGAIN YOUNG PEOPLE IS NOT
THE ONLY PLACE WHERE WE WERE
INVESTED.
WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
CALIFORNIA.
WAS BECOMING HEALTHIER. FOR SO
LONG WE AFRAID FOR SO LONG WE'VE
BEEN MAKING SURE THAT MORE AND
MORE CALIFORNIANS HAVE INSURANCE
THANKS TO THE AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT WE WENT FROM 78% INSURED.
292% ENSURE.
THAT GAP IS GOING TO GET SMALLER
THAT THEY PERCENT GAP IS GOING
TO GET SMALLER TODAY.
BY INVESTING SEVENTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS WE EXTENDED
YOUNG ADULTS ACCESS EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY SIX YEAR OLD ACCESS TO
MEDICAL.
WE ALSO RESTORED MANY OF THE
DRASTIC MEDI CAL CUTS THAT WERE
REALLY DRACONIAN CUTS IN THE
RECESSION OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
WE ALSO HEARD FROM MIDDLE CLASS
CALIFORNIANS THAT THEY NEEDED
HELP WITH COVERED CALIFORNIA
PREMIUMS. FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR COVERED
CALIFORNIA PREMIUMS FOR OUR
MIDDLE CLASS OR HAVING A HARD
TIME AFFORDING HEALTH CARE.
BUT AGAIN THAT'S OUR MIDDLE
CLASS WE KNOW WE STILL HAVE ONE
IN FIVE CALIFORNIA'S TODAY
LIVING IN POVERTY.
AND THAT HAS TO BE SOMETHING
THAT IS ONE OF OUR MAJOR FOCUS
IS.
SO WE EXPANDED.
THE RATES AT THE DEVELOPMENTAL
CENTERS.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
IT'S NOT WHAT THEY NEED BUT IT'S
A HUGE DOWN PAYMENT. FOR THE
FUTURE.
WE ALSO CONTINUED. TO ADD MORE
MONEY TO OUR CAL WORKS PROGRAM.
BECAUSE FOR SOUL FOR SO LONG
FOREST'S CALIFORNIANS.
REALLY WE'RE NOT GETTING THE
HELP THEY NEEDED FROM OUR STATE.
WE ALSO AS AS MEMBERS YOU ALL
KNOW WE HAVE A CRISIS.
OF HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS.
IN THIS STATE.
SO WE ARE INVESTING ALMOST TWO
BILLION DOLLARS.
IN HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION
SERVICES HOW AFFORDABLE HOUSING
TAX CREDITS.
IN LOCAL HOUSING PRODUCTION TO
DEAL WITH THAT AFFORDABILITY
CRISIS.
WE'RE ALSO NOT SACRIFICING OUR
ENVIRONMENT.
WE'RE PAYING A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS IN TO
CLEAN IT AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER.
ALMOST A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
AND A FIRE FAR CAPACITY
[inaudible]
AND AGAIN -- OVER A BILLION
DOLLARS WILL BE SPENT IN TO OUR
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM TO REDUCE
OUR GREENHOUSE GASES.
AND LASTLY MEMBERS.
WE OFFICE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE SAFE.
SO WE ARE MAKING SURE THAT
JUDICIAL BRANCH HOUSE ACCESS TO
RESOURCES THAT THEY DESERVE FOR
TOO LONG.
THAT'S A BRANCH THAT WE HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO MAKE THE KIND
INVESTMENTS THEY DESERVE.
WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
AS MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE GET
THE KIND OF LEGAL SERVICES THEY
DESERVE BECAUSE WE CAN'T HAVE A
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
IF ONLY ONE SIDE GETS A LEGAL
HELP THAT THEY CAN PAY.
FOR AGAIN MEMBERS TODAY I'M VERY
PROUD THEY JUST WANT TO THANK
ALL THE MEMBERS OF OUR BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
WE HAD FIVE AMAZING SUBCOMMITTEE
CHAIRS WE HAD OVER THIRTY
MEMBERS OF THIS BODY BE ON THAT
BUDGET COMMITTEE.
HOURS AND HOURS OF WORK I ALSO
WANT TO A PARTICULAR THANK.
THE ENTIRE BUDGET COMMITTEE
STAFF BOTH FOR THE MAJORITY
CAUCUS IN THE MINORITY CAUCUS
THEY ARE THE ONES WHO REALLY
HAVE DONE SO MUCH HARD WORK.
THEY WERE UP TILL THREE O'CLOCK
IN THE MORNING MAKING SURE THIS
BUDGET GOT PUT IN PRINT -- OVER
THE WEEKEND.
IT WITHOUT MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
FOR AB.
SEVENTY FOUR THANK YOU MISTER
TAME MISTER OBERNOLTE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I'D LIKE TO JOIN MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO IN
THANKING ALL OF YOU WHO HAVE
BEEN PART OF THE BUDGET PROCESS --
THERE BEEN HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS
OF HOURS OF HEARINGS OVER THE
LAST SIX MONTHS AND I KNOW IT
TAKES A LOT OF WORK FOR EVERYONE
IN THIS CHAMBER TO CRAFT THE
BUDGET.
I ALSO LIKE TO JOIN HIM AND
THINKING ALL OF OUR STAFF WE SAY
THAT WE WORK HARD BUT OUR STAFF
WORKS MUCH HARDER.
AND IT'S BEEN A HERCULEAN EFFORT
TO GET THIS BUDGET A TO THE
STATE IT'S IN TODAY.
I WANT TO START BY SAYING THAT
THERE'S A LOT TO LIKE ABOUT THIS
BUDGET.
WE'RE MAKING VERY MEANINGFUL
CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR STATE
RESERVES IN FACT WILL FINISH THE
YEAR WITH ALMOST TWENTY BILLION
DOLLARS OF RESERVES WHICH IS THE
LARGEST RESERVE IN CALIFORNIA
STATE HISTORY.
BUT TO PUT THAT IN PERSPECTIVE
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
ESTIMATES THAT EVEN A MODERATE
RECESSION WILL HAVE A SEVENTY
BILLION DOLLAR IMPACT ON STATE
REVENUE AND THAT THE TOTAL
IMPACT ON STATE BUDGETS OVER A
MULTI YEAR CYCLE WILL BE ON THE
ORDER OF FORTY BILLION DOLLARS
SO.
IF OUR GOAL IS A STATE.
IS TO HAVE A RESERVE POLICY THAT
SUFFICIENT TO HAVE THE STATE BE
ABLE TO WEATHER A RECESSION
WITHOUT EITHER RAISING TAXES OR
CUTTING SERVICES OF THE TIME
WHEN IT'S LEAST CAN AFFORD TO DO
THAT.
THEN WE'RE ABOUT HALFWAY THERE
SO THIS RESERVE POLICY IS A GOOD
START WE'RE GONNA NEED TO STAY
THE COURSE AND TO MAKE SURE WE
GET THEIR OVER THE NEXT COUPLE
OF YEARS.
HOWEVER I REALLY DISAGREE WITH
THE WAY THAT WE'RE INVESTING
THAT THE REST OF OUR BUDGET
SURPLUS WE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
WITH THE SURPLUS TO SHORE UP OUR
STATE SERVICES AND TO MAKE SURE
THAT WERE FOR FILLING THE
PROMISES THAT WE MADE TO
CALIFORNIA.
IN THE BASIC SERVICES THE STATE
PROVIDES AND UNFORTUNATELY WE'VE
ELECTED INSTEAD TO EXPAND OUR
PROGRAMS IN TO CREATE NEW
PROGRAMS AND I'LL GIVE YOU A
COUPLE OF EXAMPLE.
STARTING WITH MEDI CAL.
THIS BUDGET PROPOSES A
SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE IN
ENROLLMENT FOR MEDI CAL AND THIS
IS AN ERA WHEN MEDI CAL IS
ALREADY FAILING TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES TO THE PEOPLE THAT NEED
IT MOST IN CALIFORNIA.
EVERY DAY OF MY DISTRICT OFFICES
GETS CALLS FROM MY CONSTITUENTS
WHO ARE UNABLE TO SEE A DOCTOR
EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE TECHNICALLY
COVERED BY MEDICARE BECAUSE FOR
SO FEW DOCTORS IN MY DISTRICT.
ARE ABLE TO TAKE THE LOW
REIMBURSEMENT RATES THAT MEDI
CAL PROVIDES.
WE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO FIX
THAT WITH THIS BUDGET AND WE'RE
NOT DOING IT.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT K. TWELVE EDUCATION.
THIS BUDGET PROVIDES A MODEST
INCREASE IN PER STUDENT SPENDING
BY MODEST I MEAN ABOUT IN LINE
WITH INFLATION WILL BRING US UP
TO JUST OVER TWELVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
PER STUDENT BUT TO PUT THAT IN
PERSPECTIVE.
ADJUSTED FOR THE COST OF LIVING
IN CALIFORNIA THAT'S STILL RANKS
AS FORTY FIRST.
OUT OF THE FIFTY STATES SO GIVEN
THAT STATISTIC IT'S NO SURPRISE
THAT OUR TEACHER TO STUDENT
RATIO IS THE LOWEST HERE THAN IN
ANY STATE IN THE COUNTRY WE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CORRECT THAT
PROBLEM WITH HIS BUDGET AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE FEELING TO
DO THAT.
AND LASTLY I WOULD BE REMISS IF
I DIDN'T MENTION.
THE UNPRECEDENTED NUMBER OF
LEGISLATIVE YOUR MARKS IN THIS
BUDGET QUICKLY WE CALL THAT WORK.
THIS BUDGET HAS MORE PORK IN IT
THAN ANY OTHER BUDGET THAT I
HAVE SEEN IN MY TIME IN THE
LEGISLATURE.
YEAH MOST TROUBLING IS THE
PROCESS THAT WAS FOLLOWED WHEN
THESE ITEMS WERE ADDED.
ON SUNDAY MORNING -- DOZENS AND
DOZENS OF LEGISLATIVE YOUR MARKS
MYSTERIOUSLY WERE ADDED TO THE
BUDGET.
AND THE BUDGET CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE VOTED ON THOSE ITEMS
ON SUNDAY NIGHT THAT'S HOW QUICK
IT WAS IF YOU ADD UP THOSE EXTRA
ITEMS THAT'S OVER A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS OF
LEGISLATIVE YOUR MARKS.
THAT IS NOT A TRANSPARENT
PROCESS COLLEAGUES AND THOSE
YOUR MARKS HAVE NO BUSINESS
BEING IN THE BUDGET AT THAT LATE
DATE.
SO GIVEN OF THOSE.
PROBLEMS UNFORTUNATELY MUST URGE
A NO VOTE ON AB.
SEVENTY FOUR THINK OF A STRUGGLE
TO MISTER MEDINA.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BUDGET.
AS HAS BEEN STATED THIS IS A
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE BUDGET.
WITH NINETEEN POINT FOUR BILLION
IN RESERVE FOR FUTURE RAINY DAYS.
IT INCLUDES INVESTMENTS IN
EDUCATION COMBAT IN HOMELESSNESS
AND SOCIAL SERVICES.
IN PARTICULAR I AM PLEASED TO
SEE THREE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS DEDICATED TO THE MISSION
HERITAGE PLAZA IN MY DISTRICT.
A MIXED USE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
COMMUNITY.
AS CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE ON
HIGHER EDUCATION I AM PLEASED TO
SEE FIFTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS
BEING PUT.
FORWARD TOWARDS ADDRESSING
STUDENT HUNGER AND HOMELESSNESS
ACROSS BOTH THE UC AND CSU
SYSTEMS. FORTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS TO INCREASE RESIDENT
UNDERGRADUATE ENROLLMENT.
AT UC AND EIGHTY FIVE MILLION TO
INCREASE ENROLLMENT AT CSU.
I AM PROUD OF THIS BUDGET AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA
[inaudible]
MR MATHIS [inaudible]
YOUR REDLANDS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
YOU KNOW THIS BUDGETS REALLY THE
GOOD THE BAD AND THE UGLY.
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS HERE
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON FOR
YEARS.
THINGS LIKE PRE K. [inaudible]
SUMMER SCHOOL.
MAKING SURE SOME OF OUR CAP AND
TRADE DOLLARS ACTUALLY GO TO LOW
CARBON [inaudible]
INCREASING.
THE RATES FOR MEDI CAL PROVIDERS.
INCREASING CAL WORKS.
MAKING SURE THE VICTIMS OF THE
CAMPFIRE.
GET TAKEN CARE OF IN INCREASING
THE AMOUNT OF JOBS SHIPS THAT WE
HAVE. FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
[inaudible]
BUT SADLY [inaudible]
WE CONTINUE.
WITH MISGUIDED PRIORITIES.
WE'RE NOT PUTTING CALIFORNIA'S
FIRST.
WE'RE NOT PUTTING OUR VETERANS
WE'RE NOT PUTTING OUR PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES FIRST.
WE'RE NOT PUTTING CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES AT FIRST.
INSTEAD THE BIGGEST INCREASE TO
THIS BUDGET.
IS FOR PEOPLE WHO AREN'T EVEN
CITIZENS.
AND SO WHEN WE LOOK AT THIS AND
WE LOOK AT THESE PRIORITIES.
IT'S ALL MESSED UP.
THE IN HOUSE OF MY COLLEAGUE
FROM BIG BEAR SAID.
THIS IS GOT TO BE THE PORTEOUS
BUDGET WE'VE EVER SEEN.
I I THINK.
THAT NOT EVEN PORKY PIG COULD DO
A BETTER JOB AT THE PARK IN THIS.
BUT WE GET WE CONTINUE.
AND WE'RE WE'RE GONNA SAY ALL
THESE GREAT THINGS ABOUT THESE
SMALL MARGINAL INCREASES THAT
WE'VE DONE THAT HAVE BEEN A LONG
INFLATION RATES.
BUT WE'RE NOT DOING NEARLY
ENOUGH.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT HELPING THE
DISABLED COMMUNITY BUT WE'RE
JUST BARELY GIVEN A LITTLE BIT.
I HOPE WE CAN FIX THAT WITH SOME
TRAILER BILL'S.
GOING FORWARD.
BEFORE WE CLOSE OUT THE SESSION
THIS YEAR.
I I THINK THERE'S A LOT MORE WE
COULD BE DOING FOR OUR VETERANS.
IN THE BIGGEST THING WHEN WE
START TALKING ABOUT HEALTHCARE
FOR ALL IS THE ACCESS PORTION.
AND MEMBERS I SAT AND BUDGETS OF
ONE AND WE FOUGHT TO LOOK AT
THINGS TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
PROVIDERS THAT'S THE DOCTORS.
THAT OUR FAMILIES ARE HAVING TO
WAIT TO GO SEE.
SO WHAT WE'RE DOING AS I'VE SAID
BEFORE AS WE ARE INFLATING THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE.
THAT ARE GOING TO BE ON THE
SYSTEM.
BUT WE ARE NOT INCREASING.
THE CAPACITY LEVEL WE'RE NOT
GETTING.
MORE DOCTORS IN THEIR WE'RE NOT
DOING ANYTHING TO HELP THEM.
IN TO HELP GET MORE PROVIDERS TO
BE ABLE TO TAKE THIS INFLUX.
IT'S GREAT THAT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE EVERYBODY IS HEALTHY WE ALL
ONE HEALTHY COMMUNITIES WE ALL
WANT.
SAFETY INTERVIEWS WE ALL WANT
THESE THINGS.
BUT IT'S A MATTER OF PRIORITIES
AND HOW WE DO IT AND HOW WE'RE
TAKING CARE OF CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES.
AND PUTTING THEM FIRST.
NUMBERS I ASKED THAT WE GET OUR
PRIORITIES STRAIGHT AND I'M
ASKING FOR NO VOTE ON THIS PORK.
MR MCCARTY.
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU THAT MISTER SPEAKER I
ALSO WENT TO RISE IN SUPPORT AND
HE STEPPED AWAY BUT I WANT TO
THANK OUR BUDGET SHARE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO FOR ONCE AGAIN.
DOING AN OUTSTANDING JOB TO TO
BRING US TO A SPENDING PLAN THAT
REPRESENTS OUR VALUES -- AS WAS
NOTED THIS IS A SOUND BUDGET --
IT'S ON TIME AND FOR ALL THE
TALK ABOUT HOW MUCH WE HAVE IN
THE SURPLUS ROUGHLY THREE
QUARTERS IS SPENT ON ONE TIME
ISSUES FOR OUR RESERVES NEARLY
NINETEEN BILLION DOLLARS.
PAYING DOWN OUR WALLET DEBTS
FOCUSING ON A RETIREMENT OUR
SISTERS AND PURRS NEED SO THIS
REALLY IS A RESPONSIBLE PLAN I
WANT TO TALK FOR A FEW MOMENTS
ABOUT EDUCATION THE ISSUE THAT I
WORK ON AS CHAIR BUDGET SUB TO
AND FRANKLY.
ALL OF OUR TOP PRIORITY AND THIS
BUDGET ADDRESSES I'M GONNA SAY
OUR PRIORITIES OUR COLLECTIVE
AND I'M SAYING AGAIN OUR
BIPARTISAN COLLECTOR PRIORITIES
FROM ALL OF OUR DISTRICTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
AND I WANT TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
THIS MEANS IN PLAIN ENGLISH BACK
HOME IN YOUR DISTRICT -- ARE
BUDGETS HERE OUTLINED SOME
SPECIFICS THAT OF THE OF THE
ISSUES BUT I'LL TALK ABOUT HOW
THIS IMPACTS FAMILIES AND KIDS
IN OUR DISTRICTS -- FOCUSING ON
FIRST OUR YOUNGEST LEARNERS WE
KNOW THAT.
ECT MATTERS PRE K. MATTERS IT'S
A PROVEN DIFFERENCE MAKER HOW WE
BUILD UPON OUR ASSEMBLY BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION AND INVEST IN
THE FUTURE.
OVER TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
FAMILIES WHO WERE ON A WAITING
LIST WILL NOW BE ABLE TO ENROLL
THEIR KIDS AND EITHER FULL DAY
PRESCHOOL OR FULL DATE CHILD
CARE.
AND THIS WILL HELP THOSE
YOUNGSTERS BE PREPARED TO
SUCCEED IN KINDERGARTEN AND ALSO
HELP THEIR FAMILIES -- GO TO
WORK.
ALSO FOR THE FIRST TIME FOR OUR
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS YOU
HEARD FROM YOUR CONSTITUENTS
THAT TOO MANY FAMILIES.
ARE TOO RICH MAYBE THEY MAKE
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR A FAMILY OF FOUR TO GET FREE
PRESCHOOL BUT THEY'RE WAY TOO
POOR TO PAY UC BERKELEY TYPE
TUITION. FOR FIFTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH TO SEND THEIR
LITTLE ONES TO PRESCHOOL SO NOW
FOR THE FIRST TIME.
IF YOU WERE THESE MIDDLE INCOME
FAMILIES AND YOU LIVE IN A HIGH
POVERTY NEIGHBORHOODS YOU'LL BE
ABLE TO GO TO OUR STATE FUNDED
PRESCHOOLS.
REGARDLESS OF YOUR INCOME SO WE
HELP MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES
THAT'S A BIG WIN IN THIS BUDGET.
AS FIRES HIGHER EDUCATION AS OUR
HIRE A CHAIR NOTED EARLIER THIS
EXPANDS ACCESS TO OUR UC AND CSU
WHAT DOES THIS MEAN EVERY SPRING
I GUARANTEE YOU SEE PEOPLE OUT
YOUR FARMERS MARKETS THE GROCERY
STORES THE LITTLE LEAGUE IN
SOCCER FIELDS.
AND THEY SAY MY NEPHEW.
MY NEIGHBOR MY SON MY DAUGHTER
APPLY TO THE UC THEY HAVE A FOUR
POINT THREE GPA THEY DIDN'T GET
IN WERE ENROLLING TOO MANY KIDS
FROM OUT OF CALIFORNIA.
WELL THIS YEAR IN OUR BUDGET WE
WE GREEN LIGHT FIVE THOUSAND NEW
ENROLLMENTS LOTS FOR THE INVERSE
OF CALIFORNIA THE HIGHEST NUMBER
WE'VE EVER.
PUT IN A BUDGET TO EXPAND ACCESS
FOR OUR CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
OVER AT THE CSU WITH ABOUT
THIRTY THOUSAND KIDS EVERY YEAR
THAT APPLY FOR CSU BUT ARE
DENIED ADMISSION THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE RATED AGO WE DON'T FUND
THE SLOTS. TEN THOUSAND NOR
SLOTS IN THIS BUDGET.
FREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
REGARDLESS OF HOW MUCH INCOME
YOU MAKING CALIFORNIA FOR YOUR
FIRST TWO YEARS AFTER HIGH
SCHOOL YOU'LL BE ABLE TO GO TO
COLLEGE FOR FREE JUST LIKE YOU
CAN'T FOR ELEVENTH AND TWELFTH
GRADE. FOR OUR CAL GRANT PROGRAM
WE KNOW THAT THE TICKET. TO TO
HIGHER EDUCATION IS IS FUNDING
ACCESS TO COLLEGE AND WE KNOW
THAT IT'S NOT JUST TUITION
ANYMORE IT'S OTHER BOOKS AND
HOUSING AND SO FORTH SO.
ON OUR STUDENTS PARENTS WE HAVE
A PROPOSAL IS GOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT STUDENT PARENTS CAN
GRADUATE DEBT FREE AND THE
STUDENTS AND APPLY FOR COLLEGE
IN THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM.
COUPLE YEARS AFTER HIGH SCHOOL
IF THE COMPETITIVE SLOT WE
ALMOST DOUBLE THE NUMBER OF
COMPETITIVE -- CAL GRANT AWARDS.
LASTLY FOR A LITTLE MIXED BAG I
CAN KERR WITH OUR MINORITY A
BUDGET LEADER ON OUR K. --
TWELVE BUDGETS WE DO HAVE NEARLY
THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN NEW
MONIES FOR OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS
THAT'S GOOD NEWS WE'VE INCREASE
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
EDUCATION FUNDING.
BY THIRTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
THIRTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS WE
HAVE MONIES FOR AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS WHICH HELP KIDS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR FAMILIES WE
INCREASE SPECIAL LET FUNDING
WITH ALL OF YOUR DISTRICTS HAVE
TALKED ABOUT.
AS A PRIORITY BUT WE'RE STILL
FORTY FIRST IN THE NATION IN PER
PUPIL FUNDING SO THIS FRANKLY IS
A REALITY CHECK WE'VE DONE JUST
ABOUT ALL WE CAN DO.
JUST ABOUT ALL WE CAN DO TO
SQUIRREL MONEY TO OUR TOP
PRIORITY.
PUBLIC EDUCATION PUBLIC
EDUCATION BUT WE STILL HAVE
DOZENS OF DISTRICTS ON THE BIBLE.
MY DISTRICT HERE IN SACRAMENTO
LOS ANGELES OAKLAND THAT ARE
STRUGGLING MIGHTILY SO WE NEED
TO HAVE A REALITY CHECK TO US AS
FAR AS WHAT OUR VALUES WHAT ARE
WE WILLING TO FIND. FOR PUBLIC
EDUCATION BECAUSE WE'VE DONE A
LOT HERE BUT IT'S NOT NEARLY
ENOUGH WE STILL HAVE RIDICULOUS
CLASS SIZES SCHOOLS THAT DON'T
HAVE THE BASICS THAT WE REMEMBER
WE WERE KIDS ARTS MUSIC P. ET --
WE HAVE MUCH MORE WORK TO BE
DONE IN THIS EDUCATION AROUND SO
I AM A STRONG I IN THE BUDGET
BUT IT'S A REMINDER ABOUT MORE
WORK NEEDS TO BE DONE. FOR A
PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA THANK.
DAVIS MCCARTY DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I FIRST WANT TO START BY
THANKING YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
MISTER SPEAKER ON THIS BUDGET AS
WELL AS THE CHAIR OF BUDGET.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE WHEN
WE HAVE A FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE
BUDGET THAT STILL STRIVES TO
MAKE TRUE PROGRESSIVE SOCIAL
CHANGE.
AND THIS BUDGET DOES JUST THAT.
I WANTED TO TAKE A MOMENT IF I
COULD. TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CONCERNS FROM ACROSS THE AISLE.
BECAUSE IT'S OVERLY SIMPLISTIC
TO LOOK AT ANY SINGLE PART OF
HEALTH CARE.
AND TWO ISOLATED WITHIN ABOVE.
JUST LIKE YOU CAN'T SQUEEZE A
WATER BALLOON AND NOT EXPECT
THERE TO BE.
SQUEEZING HAPPENING IN OTHER
PLACES I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US TO LOOK AT THE TOTALITY
OF HEALTH CARE SPENDING.
SO IF I CAN BEGIN I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE MEDICARE I'LL RATE
INCREASES THAT OCCURRED LAST
YEAR WITH PROP.
FIFTY SIX THAT WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY ALLOW PROVIDERS TO
KEEP THEIR LIGHTS ON AND THEIR
DOORS OPEN AND TO ENSURE THAT WE
CAN TAKE CARE OF MEDI CAL
PATIENTS.
I ALSO WANT TO SPEAK ABOUT THE
LOAN REPAYMENT PROGRAM THAT WE
DID LAST YEAR THAT WILL
INCENTIVIZE PROVIDERS TO TAKE
CARE OF MEDI CAL PATIENTS.
FINALLY FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM
THE VALLEY.
WE DID INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
PROVIDERS IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY BY HAVING A MEDICAL
SCHOOL START IN FRESNO LAST YEAR
START TRAINING PROVIDERS.
NOW IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
INCREASE THAT AND FIGURE OUT HOW
WE CAN MAKE SURE OUR MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
ARE ABLE TO ACCESS CARE.
NOW THAT BEING SAID.
I AM GRATEFUL.
THAT WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO EXPAND
COVERAGE TO EVERY CALIFORNIAN
BETWEEN THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN AND
TWENTY SIX IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US.
TO ALSO LOOK AT HOW WE CAN
INCREASE THE ASSISTANCE THAT WE
GIVE THOSE WHO ARE CURRENTLY ON
COVERED CALIFORNIA. TO ENSURE
THAT THEY CAN AFFORD THE CARE
THAT THEY RECEIVE.
THE FUNDING THAT WE'VE INCLUDED
AND HAVE WILL USE TO HIRE
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AS WELL AS
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PURE
NAVIGATORS IN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS WILL ALLOW US TO
CREATE A MORE EFFICIENT HEALTH
CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM.
AND TO GET PEOPLE THE TREATMENT
THEY NEED WHERE THEY NEED.
THE FUNDING THAT WE HAD FOR
TRAUMA SCREENING INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WILL ALSO
ALLOW US TO DO THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND TRAINING FOR
PROVIDERS TO IMPROVE THE HEALTH
AND WELL BEING OF OUR CHILDREN.
THE FUNDING THAT WAS INCLUDED AS
A NUMBER OF OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
INVESTMENTS INTO BOTH STDS AND
HIV PREVENTION AS WELL AS ASTHMA
PREVENTION AND REMEDIATION
SERVICES TO NAME JUST A FEW.
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF OUR FAMILY
URGENT RESPONSE SYSTEM TO HELP
ESTABLISH AND MAINTAIN A
STATEWIDE HOTLINE TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN FOR CARE GIVERS AND FOR
FOSTER YOUTH.
WHO EXPERIENCE EMOTIONAL
BEHAVIORAL OR OTHER DIFFICULTIES
IN NEED OF IMMEDIATE HELP?
THE FUNDING FOR THE IMMIGRANT
JUSTICE FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM TO
GROW THE NUMBER OF IMMIGRANT
ATTORNEYS AND NON PROFITS
PROVIDING REPRESENTATION OF
REMOVAL DEFENSE REPRESENTATION
IS IMPORTANT FOR COMMUNITIES
LIKE MINE.
BUT I COME HERE TODAY WEARING A
BLUE COLLAR.
NOT FOR ANY OTHER REASON BUT TO
HELP TO REMIND ME OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT I COME FROM.
BECAUSE WE ARE A BLUE COLLAR
COMMUNITY.
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW AS A
STATE TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
INVESTING OUR BUDGET INTO
SUPPORTING BLUE COLLAR
COMMUNITIES.
AND THIS BUDGET DOES JUST THAT.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT I'M PROUD TO
ADD MY SUPPORT AND URGE YOUR
SUPPORT ON AB.
SEVENTY FOUR THANK YOU DOCTOR IN
THE MISS WALDRON.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS AS WAS STATED THIS
BUDGET HAS A LOT OF GOOD THINGS
IN IT ACTUALLY IT'S QUITE A BIT --
AS WELL AS THE PORK THAT WE ALL
TALKED ABOUT -- BUT I'M HAPPY TO
SEE THE GOVERNOR CONTINUES TO
PRIORITIZE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES IN HIS BUDGET.
THE NEW BUDGET INCLUDES A
HUNDRED MILLION TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS.
BUT WE HAVE TO DO MORE TO ENSURE
THAT EFFECTIVE TREATMENT IS
AVAILABLE. FOR CALIFORNIANS
STRUGGLING WITH ADDICTION.
LIKE FUNDING MEDICATION ASSISTED
TREATMENT AT NARCOTIC TREATMENT
PROGRAMS AND THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE'VE BEEN.
TRYING TO FIGHT FOR FOR YEARS
AND IT'S STILL NOT ADDRESS.
WHAT ABOUT -- DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES COMMUNITY.
WE CAN DO MORE.
BUT ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
COIN NOT ALL CAREERS REQUIRE A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE.
IN FACT MANY CAREERS IN THE
TRADES PROVIDE MIDDLE CLASS
SALARIES THE CAN'T BE AUTOMATED
LIKE OTHER JOBS.
AND IT'S GOOD TO SEE A BUDGET
THAT INVESTS IN CAREER TAX
EDUCATION.
AT OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
[inaudible]
HOWEVER.
THE DMV GETS A BLANK CHECK. TWO
HUNDRED FORTY TWO POINT ONE
MILLION.
FOR TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND
ONE NINETY NINE POINT EIGHT
MILLION FOR TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE ALLOWING FOR MORE IF
REQUIRED BASICALLY A BLANK CHECK.
FAR TOO GENEROUS FOR DEPARTMENT
RIDDLED WITH PROBLEMS.
BUT ON A GOOD NOTE.
THERE ARE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
FOR CAL FIRE. FOR MORE YEAR
ROUND ENGINES HEAVY EQUIPMENT
STAFFING AND SEE ONE THIRTY AIR
TANKERS BUT THIS BUDGET DOES
NOTHING TO HELP LOCAL AGENCIES
REDUCE THE THREAT OF WILDFIRES
CAUSED BY VEHICLES.
IN SAN DIEGO NEARLY 25% OF
WILDFIRES WAS STARTED BY
VEHICLES.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND 201725%.
WE CAN PREVENT UP TO ONE QUARTER
OF WILDFIRES STATEWIDE.
BUT THIS ITEM WAS IGNORED IN THE
BUDGET DESPITE SUPPORT FROM FIRE
AGENCIES FIRE CHIEFS AND RURAL
COUNTIES.
AS WAS STATED A HUGE A HUGE
PRIORITY -- THE NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED AND HAS BEEN AN ISSUE
YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR IS
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE. ONE BIG
STEP WOULD BE INCREASING
REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR
PHYSICIANS AND PROVIDERS A
MINUTE KILL.
MEDI CAL AN EFFORT TO INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF PROVIDERS.
IN OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
YET THIS BUDGET OPENS UP MEDI
CAL TO MORE ENROLLEES WITHOUT
ADDRESSING THE PROBLEM OF AXIS.
SO IN ADDITION TO MY COLLEAGUE
FROM BIG BEAR'S COMMONS.
I WILL NOT BE SUPPORTING THE
BUDGET TODAY I THINK THERE'S
MORE THAT WE COULD DO ON OUR
PRIORITIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON MISTER
LEVINE.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THANK
YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU TO OUR OUR
BUDGET SHARES ARE LEGISLATIVE
LEADERS GOVERNOR NEW SOME FOR
NEGOTIATING -- WHAT IS PERHAPS
THE THE GREATEST BUDGET I'VE HAD
AN OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE FOR IN
I'VE I'VE HEARD IT REFERRED TO
IN AND I'LL CALL IT.
WHAT THIS BUDGET APPEARS TO BE
LIKE THIS BUDGET?
IS A UNICORN IN A SENSE IT'S
NEVER BEFORE BEEN SEEN CERTAINLY
NOT BY LEGISLATORS IN THIS
GENERATION ONE THAT COMES WITH
US WITH AN TO US WITH AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEND.
ON SO MANY DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
THAT WE'VE BEEN LOOKING TO LIFT
UP SINCE THE GREAT RECESSION. TO
LIFT OUR SCHOOLS OUT OF OUT OF
IT THE LOWS OF FUNDING. TO PAY
DOWN BILLIONS IN PENSION DAT.
AND INTO STOCK AWAY OVER
NINETEEN BILLION DOLLARS IN A
RAINY DAY FUND THAT WAS SET UP
BY THIS LEGISLATURE IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN I WITH THE VOTERS
APPROVAL.
BUT WE KNOW THAT UNICORNS DON'T
EXIST.
AND BUT JUST LIKE THIS ARE MORE
OF A MIRAGE AND THAT IS WHY THE
RAINY DAY FUND AND THOSE ONE
TIME PAYMENTS ARE SO IMPORTANT
TO MAKE OUR FUTURE YEARS.
A WHOLE LOT EASIER.
AND I THINK IT SHOWS THE
DISCIPLINE.
OF THE LEGISLATURE THAT SINCE WE
WERE ELECTED WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
PAY DOWN THAT WALL OF DAT.
OR WHAT I LIKE.
TO THINK OF IS MORE OF A PIT OF
BUDGETARY DESPAIR.
THAT WE ARE ON BURDEN BY.
INTO THE FUTURE AND SO I THANK
YOU. FOR THAT DISCIPLINE OVER
ALL OF THOSE YEARS AND I'M
GRATEFUL THAT GOVERNOR NEW SOME
HAS HELPED US TO FINISH THIS OFF
SO THAT HE THAT HE DOESN'T ALSO
NEED TO BE WEIGHTED DOWN.
DURING HIS TIME AS GOVERNOR.
I DID HEAR SOMETHING EARLIER
THAT -- THAT OFFENDED ME THOUGH.
AND I WANT TO TALK ABOUT.
THE WAY THAT WE FIND THINGS IN
THAT ARE MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY.
WE WERE TOLD THAT WE'RE DOING
SOMETHING FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
AMERICAN.
WE HAVE AN ECONOMIC AND AN
ECONOMY.
AND AND IMMIGRATION SYSTEM.
THAT DON'T WORK TOGETHER BUT
DEPEND ON ONE ANOTHER AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
WON'T TAKE A DANCE LESSON TO
FIGURE THAT OUT.
BUT THAT DOESN'T AFFECT US AND
HOW WE TREAT.
OUR NEIGHBORS AND MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY.
AND THERE IS NO OTHER REASON WE
NEED TO JUSTIFY.
HOW WE SPEND THIS MONEY IN FACT
IT DEMEANS?
HOW WE SPEND THIS MONEY?
WHEN WE TRY TO JUSTIFY SPENDING
MONEY TO SUPPORT OUR NEIGHBORS
IN CALIFORNIA?
I AM LOOKING FOR THE CASTING MY
AYE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS.
THANK YOU MITCHELL OF MAINE
DOCTOR WOULD.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BUDGET AND
APPRECIATIVE OF ALL THE WORK
THAT'S GONE INTO THAT -- I DO
WANT TO POINT OUT.
SOME THINGS AND AS IT THEM
REGARDING HEALTH CARE IN
REGARDING.
WHAT I DIDN'T HEAR ABOUT A
POPULATION OF FOLKS THAT?
I THINK A REALLY IMPORTANT TO
OUR SOCIETY.
THEY SAY ARE BUDGETS A
REFLECTION OF OUR VALUES AND
WHAT I DIDN'T HEAR WAS.
ABOUT INVESTMENTS IN SOME OF OUR
SENIORS -- WE HAVE INVESTED HUGE
AMOUNTS IN EDUCATION I'M
COMPLETELY SUPPORTIVE I'M
SUPPORTIVE OF ALL THE AT ALL THE
OTHER INVESTMENTS WERE MAKING
FOR FOR FIRE PREVENTION FOR IT
FOR FOR ALL THESE OTHER PROGRAMS
FOR HEALTH CARE ALL THESE
EXPANSIONS.
AND THEIR HUGE NUMBERS THE
NUMBERS THAT I'M TALKING ABOUT
OUR SMALL NUMBERS THAT AFFECT
THE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR SOME OF
OUR MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE.
WE ABOUT OMBUDSMAN PROGRAM FOR
PEOPLE LIVE IN SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES THAT PROGRAM HELPS.
PREVENT BAD OUTCOMES FOR PEOPLE
WHO LIVE IN THESE FACILITIES
THERE ARE THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE MEMBERS THAT LIVE IN A
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY -- 40%
OF THOSE FOLKS DON'T HAVE
ANYBODY TO REGULARLY VISIT THEM.
AND THIS SMALL PROGRAM OF THIS
PROGRAM THAT MAYBE WE JUST ABOUT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS MORE.
COULD HELP PROTECT THOSE SENIORS
SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO GO
AFTER AND BUYING OF FACILITIES
WE CAN ACTUALLY WORK PROACTIVELY
TO HELP PROTECT PEOPLE IN THESE
ENVIRONMENTS -- THAT'S JUST ONE
EXAMPLE OF OF SOMETHING WE COULD
DO FOR SENIORS AND A SMALL
AMOUNT OF MONEY COULD GO A LONG
WAY WE PUT MORE MONEY INTO
SENIOR NUTRITION.
PROGRAMS WHICH IS GREAT EVER
HEARD OF MEALS ON WHEELS I HAVE.
YOU KNOW WHO FUELS THE MEALS ON
WHEELS THE VOLUNTEERS WHO
DELIVER THE MEALS EVERY DAY AND
I FOUND OUT LAST FALL THAT A LOT
OF OUR SENIORS WERE GOING TO
LOSE A DAY A WEEK.
OF A SENIOR OF THOSE MEALS ON
WHEELS.
WHY IS THAT IMPORTANT THAT'S THE
ONLY CONTACT THAT PEOPLE GET
SOMETIMES WITH THE OUTSIDE WORLD
IS THAT DELIVERY THAT MEAL
THAT'S A HEALTH CARE THAT'S A
WELFARE CHECK AS MUCH AS IT IS A
MEAL?
THE TRASH IS TO HELP SUPPORT
PEOPLE SO I AM VERY APPRECIATIVE
THAT THE GOVERNOR IS GOING TO BE
MOVING FORWARD ON THE MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING AND I HOPE THAT A
FUTURE BUDGET REFLECTS.
THE SENIOR POPULATION THE
FASTEST GROWING POPULATION IN
OUR STATE OUR SENIORS AND GOD
WILLING WE'RE ALL GOING TO BE
THERE SOME SOME WAS ARE GETTING
CLOSER.
RIGHT NOW BUT GOD WILLING WE'RE
ALL GONNA BE THERE SOME POINT
AND BE ABLE TO LIVE THE QUALITY
OF LIFE WE WANT TO IN OUR HOMES
WITH THE BEST QUALITY CHARACTER
SO I'M I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE BUDGET.
BUT WHAT I DIDN'T HEAR WAS ABOUT
IT AND INVESTMENT IN SOME MORE
SENIORS AND I HOPE THAT WE OF
DIG DEEP AND LOOK LOOK FOR THAT
IN THE FUTURE AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MEMBERS.
THANK ADEQUATE MR HOLDEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVENTY FOUR I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE HARD WORK AND
DIFFICULT DECISIONS NECESSARY TO
COMPLETE A BUDGET.
AND TO MEET TO THAT MEETS THE
CALIFORNIA NEEDS NOW AND INTO
THE FUTURE.
THE BUDGET IS OF COURSE A
STATEMENT.
OF OUR PRIORITIES AND OUR VALUES.
I'M HAPPY TO SEE THE RATE
INCREASES TO SERVICE PROVIDERS
TO SERVE OUR RESIDENTS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
BUT THIS IS JUST A FIRST STEP.
WE HAVE A RATE STUDY THAT SHOWS
WE HAVE NEGLECTED ADEQUATELY
FUNDING THESE SERVICES BY WELL
OVER A BILLION DOLLARS.
I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH OF THE MINISTRATION
AND LEGISLATURE.
WE MUST FINISH THE WORK BEGUN
WITH THE RATE STUDY BY
IMPLEMENTING TRUE RATE REFORM.
WE MUST FAIRLY AND ETHICALLY
ADDRESS THE RISING COSTS OF
WAGES OF LOS ANGELES.
THE BAY AREA AND SAN DIEGO OR
RISK THE NINE SERVICES TO THE
MAJORITY OF OUR STATES RESIDENTS.
WHO LIVE IN THESE AREAS?
WE HAVE TAKEN AN IMPORTANT FIRST
STEP WITH THIS BUDGET AND WE
WILL CONTINUE OUR WORK SO THAT
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
RECEIVE SERVICES THAT THEY NEED.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER ABOUT.
THE THING IMAGE HOLD MISS
MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THERE'S A LOT.
OF GOOD IN THIS BUDGET.
YOU KNOW I I APPRECIATE HOW.
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
START OFF TALKING ABOUT HOW THIS
IS A RESPONSIBLE BUDGET.
EMPHASIZING HOW MUCH WE HAVE SET
ASIDE. FOR THE INEVITABLE
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN.
WITH OUR RESERVISTS OVER
NINETEEN BILLION DOLLARS THAT
WE'VE SET ASIDE IT'S A
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET.
IT'S A BALANCED BUDGET.
I ALSO APPRECIATE.
THE CHAIRMAN OF OUR BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
FOCUSING ON HOW WE ARE MAKING
SIGNIFICANT.
DOWN PAYMENTS ON OUR PENSION
LIABILITIES FOR BILLION DOLLARS
TO ADDRESS. ONE OF THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES THAT WE ARE FACING.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I HAVE TWO CONCERNS WITH THIS
BUDGET. ONE IS EDUCATION
[inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
WHAT THE BUDGET CHAIR IS IS
CORRECT THAT WE ARE ALLOCATING
EIGHTY ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT DOLLARS
MORE DOLLARS IN ANY OTHER TIME?
AW.
IN OUR HISTORY.
I HAD TO CONFIRM YESTERDAY IN
OUR BUDGET BRIEFING THAT THAT IS
STILL.
THE MINIMUM GUARANTEE UNDER
PROPOSITION.
NINETY EIGHT AND IT DISAPPOINTS
ME THAT IN THIS YEAR WELL WE HAD
OUR LA USC STRIKE OR OAKLAND
STRIKE ARE SACRAMENTO SITUATION
[inaudible]
NEW HAVEN.
WE CAN ONLY STILL FIND AT THE
MINIMUM GUARANTEE OF PROPOSITION.
NINETY EIGHT MINIMUM GUARANTEE
MEANS THAT LET'S NOT BE FULL BY.
THE DOLLAR AMOUNT WE ARE JUST
ALLOCATING THE MINIMUM.
THAT WE ARE REQUIRED TO ALLOCATE
UNDER PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
WITH THE COLA ADJUSTMENT.
THAT IS NOT BOLD MISTER GOVERNOR.
IT'S THE MINIMUM.
MY OTHER CONCERN [inaudible]
IS WITH.
THE SPENDING OF GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUNDS. FOR THE CLEAN
WATER PROGRAM I FULLY SUPPORT.
PROVIDING A MILLION PEOPLE WITH
CLEAN WATER THAT.
SHOULD BE A HUMAN RIGHT.
AND WE SHOULD MAKE IT UP AS A
PRIORITY [inaudible]
BUT I OBJECT TO THE USE OF THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUNDS.
FOR THE CLEAN WATER PROGRAM.
AS A MATTER OF THE INTEGRITY OF
THIS BUDGET.
MISS QUIRK SILVA.
YOUR RECOGNIZE FROM THE DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
BUDGETS ARE A REFLECTION OF NOT
ONLY WHO WE ARE BUT WHO WE
REPRESENT.
THEY'RE ALSO A REFLECTION OF OUR
DISTRICTS SO TODAY I WANT TO
THANK OUR A BUDGET LEADER I WANT
TO THANK THE MOST THE MEMBERS OF
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE WHO SPENT
HOURS AND HOURS LOOKING AT
PROPOSALS.
AND LIKE ANY BUDGET OUR OWN
PERSONAL BUDGETS WE ALL HAVE TO
DETERMINE THE WANTS IN THE NEEDS
SO AS FAR AS OUR INVESTMENT WE
HAVE MADE AN INVESTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND IN OUR DISTRICT WE HAVE
INVESTED IN CHILD CARE HEALTH
CARE HOUSING HOMELESSNESS
FUNDING MENTAL HEALTH FUNDING
WE'VE INVESTED IN OUR STUDENTS.
FOR STUDENT DEBT FOR MORE CAL
GRANT.
MANY MORE -- FIFTEEN THOUSAND
GRANTS FOR THE COMPETITIVE
GRANTS UP FOR STUDENTS WHO ARE
VULNERABLE FOR HOUSING FOR FOOD
AND SECURITY.
WE'VE ALSO SAID TO ALL OUR
FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS.
THAT ARE OFTEN WORKING ON OUR
HOTELS IN OUR RESTAURANTS THAT
ARE OFTEN WORKING.
IN OUR FRUIT WORKING IN THE HEAT
ON OUR FARMS WORKING IN
AGRICULTURE WE'RE INVESTING IN
YOU TOO WE BELIEVE THAT YOU ARE
DOING MUCH OF THE HARD WORK FROM
CALIFORNIA AND THAT WE ARE GOING
TO INVEST.
IN YOU FOR HEALTH CARE.
UP.
AS A REPRESENTATIVE OF ORANGE
COUNTY.
WE ARE INVESTING IN ORANGE
COUNTY WITH ORANGE COUNTY
DELEGATION.
BRINGING AND FUNDS FOR VETERANS
FOR HOUSING FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE THOSE ARE INVESTMENTS
THAT I'M PROUD OF AND I'M PROUD
TO SUPPORT THIS BUDGET.
MEMBERS OF THE LIKELY RECOGNIZE
PLEASE RAISE YOUR MICROPHONES
NOW.
THIS FRAZIER YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS --
AS I COME CLOSE TO ATTENDING THE
SUMMER SPECIAL OLYMPICS NEXT
WEEK.
AND WELL THIS BUDGET PUTS
FUNDING INTO PROGRAMS THAT SIR
CALIFORNIANS WITH INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
WE ALL HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
WE AREN'T DOING ENOUGH.
AND WE'LL DO NEED TO DO VERY
MUCH MORE.
MAYBE EVEN THIS YEAR.
AS A POSSIBILITY.
FIRST THIS BUDGET PROVIDES
FUNDING BUT DOESN'T START UNTIL
JANUARY FIRST.
AND THE FACT IS THAT SOME
PROGRAMS JUST CAN'T WAIT THAT
LONG.
SECOND THE BUDGET GIVE SOME
FUNDING TO SOME OF THE PROGRAMS.
BELIEVES MANY OUT.
AND THAT'S JUST WRONG.
THESE PROGRAMS ARE STRUGGLING
BECAUSE OUR STATE.
PAST LEGISLATORS AND GOVERNORS.
HAVE ONLY GIVEN THE SYSTEM TO
INCREASES IN TWENTY YEARS.
THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION
REJECTED GIVING INCREASES TO
SOME PROGRAMS A BELIEVE WILL BE
OUT OF FAVOR UNDER FEDERAL
GUIDELINES THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO
BE IMPLEMENTED.
IN.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO BUT THESE
TODAY THESE PROGRAMS ARE
PROVIDING SERVICES SELECTED
PEOPLE WITH IDT IN FAMILIES.
APPROVED BY THE REGIONAL CENTER
IN THEIR AREA AND YOUR AREA AND
MY DISTRICT.
UNTIL WE HAVE A PLAN FOR OTHER
OPTIONS WE SIMPLY CANNOT ABANDON
THESE PROGRAMS ARREST THEM
FAILING BECAUSE WE THINK WE
MIGHT NOT RECEIVE FEDERAL
FUNDING. THREE YEARS FROM NOW.
THIRD THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES SAID THEY
MADE THE CHOICES TO FUND
PROGRAMS THEY DID.
BASED UPON THE RATE STUDY THAT
THAT WAS RELEASED IN LATE MARCH.
BUT WE ALL NEED TO KEEP IN MIND
THAT THIS RATE STUDY IS NOT.
FINALIZEDAND NOT ACCURATE IN
MANY PLACES.
THE DEPARTMENT TOOK IN CONTENTS
FROM THE PUBLIC.
WHICH INCLUDED.
MANY ADDRESSING THE FLAWS IN THE
STUDY.
AND THE DEPARTMENT HAS YET TO
ANSWER THESE COMMENTS.
WE NEED ANSWERS AND IT'S OUR JOB
TO PROVIDE THE OVERSIGHT
NECESSARY. TO COMPEL THEM TO
ANSWER.
AND TO PUT A PLAN INTO PLACE.
LASTLY THE RACE THAT HE SAYS WE
ARE UNDER FINING THE SYSTEM BY
ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
AND I BELIEVE THAT'S AN ACCURATE
AMOUNT ALSO I THINK IT'S MORE
THAN THAT.
THIS BUDGET RESPONDS WITH A ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE MILLION
THIS YEAR.
AND TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT
MILLION ANNUALLY.
WE'RE KIND OF SHORT.
AS I SAID IN THE BEGINNING WE'RE
SHORTING THEM.
BY ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS OR
MORE.
AND WE NEED TO DO MUCH MUCH MORE.
WE'RE ALL BLESSED IN THIS ROOM
WITH A TYPICAL CHILDREN.
MANY ARE NOT.
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THE ID
POPULATION.
GOING.
FOR THANK YOU MISS FRAZIER MISS
MELENDEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
CALIFORNIA IS NUMBER ONE IN
POVERTY.
WE ARE NUMBER ONE IN
HOMELESSNESS WE ARE NUMBER ONE
IN VETERANS HOMELESSNESS.
BUT WE'RE GOING TO SPEND THREE
AND A HALF MILLION DOLLARS.
ON A DOG PARK.
HAPPEN MILLION DOLLARS ON A
SCULPTURE GARDEN. TEN MILLION
DOLLARS ON A PARKING LOT.
ARE THOSE THE VALUES.
THAT WE'RE SETTING TODAY THAT WE
WANT OUR CONSTITUENTS TO KNOW
ABOUT.
MAYBE ARE HOMELESS AND HOMELESS
VETERANS.
CAN SLEEP IN THE SCULPTURE
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT PROVIDING FOR
THEM THIS IS SHANE PAUL.
LOS ANGELES LAST YEAR SPENT OVER
HALF A BILLION DOLLARS
[inaudible]
FIGHTING HOMELESSNESS.
YOU KNOW WHAT THESE WHAT THEIR
SUCCESS WAS.
A 12% INCREASE AND HOMELESSNESS.
THE STATE BUDGET THAT WE'RE
ABOUT TO VOTE ON ALLOCATE NEARLY
THE SAME AMOUNT OF MONEY. TO
ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS IN THE
ENTIRE STATE.
SO WE SHOULD EXPECT A DIFFERENT
RESULT REALLY.
THIS IS RIDICULOUS YOU.
YOU'RE GONNA SPEND THREE TO HAVE
MILLION DOLLARS ON DOG PARKS
[inaudible]
COME ON THE HEALTH INSURANCE.
IT'S A TAX.
YOU CAN CALL IT A FEE YOU CAN
CALL TO FIND IT IS A TAX.
AND IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE ME LOOK
BACK TO WHAT HAPPENED WITH THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE FOR MAMA CARE.
THE SUPREME COURT SAID IT'S A
TAX.
AND SO IS THIS.
SO GET READY TO GET CHALLENGED
IN COURT I GUESS AND SPEND MORE
MONEY ON LEGAL FEES THIS IS A
TAX IS A TAX ON WORKING
CALIFORNIANS. TO PAPER SOMETHING
THAT LEGISLATORS WANT TO GIVE
AWAY.
YOU'RE GIVING OTHER PEOPLE'S
MONEY AWAY.
ONCE YOU GET SOME YEAR
BILLIONAIRE.
DONORS. TO PAY FOR THE HEALTH
CARE ARE THE PEOPLE YOU WANT TO
COVER.
BUT STOP ASKING CALIFORNIANS ARE
BUSTING THEIR TAILS EVERYDAY. TO
MAKE ENDS MEET TO PAPER THINGS.
FOR OTHER PEOPLE WHO AREN'T EVEN
SUPPOSED TO BE HERE.
I GET IT.
IT SEEMS OFFENSIVE TO SOME OF
YOU THAT I EVEN SAY THAT.
BUT IT'S TRUE [inaudible]
IT'S TRUE.
AND I GET EMAILS FROM DEMOCRATS
FROM.
FROM NO PARTY PREFERENCE PEOPLE
FROM REPUBLICANS ALL ACROSS THE
SPECTRUM AND THEY ALL SAY THE
SAME THING STOP SPENDING MY
MONEY ON THINGS LIKE THIS.
JUST -- TO PUT A FINAL POINT ON
IT.
RELATING TO THE HOMELESS.
I NOTICED IN THE BUDGET.
WE'RE TALKING BUT THE CONTINUUM
CONTINUUM OF CARE FACILITIES.
LOS ANGELES [inaudible]
AT IS WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR TAKING
CARE ABOUT 41%.
AT THE STATE'S HOMELESS.
HOW THAT HOW THAT WORKED OUT?
A 12% INCREASE.
SO I'M SORRY BUT FOR ALL THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE SO PROUD OF THIS
BUDGET I HAVE A VERY DIFFERENT
OPINION.
AND THOSE OF YOU WHO VOTE FOR
THIS BUDGET TODAY SHOULD HANG
YOUR HEAD IN SHAME.
MR CHILL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED I'M
JUST CAN BE VERY BRIEF -- I HAD
A PLAN TO SPEAK TODAY BUT ONE
JUST POINT TO THE FACT THAT THIS
BUDGET HAS AN UNPRECEDENTED
LEVEL.
OF EXPENDITURES FOR HOUSING AND
FOR DRESSING HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
TWO POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS --
I THINK THAT'S ALL THAT NEEDS TO
BE SAID.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU SEEING NO
OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION.
ON THE BUDGET.
ITEM MISTER TANG YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
GOVERNING IS HARD.
SERVING THE PEOPLE [inaudible]
IS DIFFICULT.
THE PROBLEMS WE HAVE IN THE
STATE [inaudible]
WERE [inaudible]
CREATED OVERNIGHT.
IN THE CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE
WON'T BE SOLVED.
OVERNIGHT.
SO WHILE I KNOW IT'S EASY TO
CRITICIZE AND THROW ROCKS AT A
PARTICULAR.
SOLUTION.
THIS IS OUR EFFORT. TO BE IN THE
GAME. TO SERVE FORTY MILLION
CALIFORNIANS [inaudible]
AGAIN.
THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF SPENDING.
FOR K. THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION
IS IT ENOUGH.
NO.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
MORE MONEY FOR HEALTH CARE FOR
MIDDLE CLASS CALIFORNIANS WHO
HAVE TROUBLE PAYING [inaudible]
PREMIUMS.
WHAT WE LOVE TO DO MORE
ABSOLUTELY?
BUT WE CAN. FIFTEEN THOUSAND
SLOTS FOR CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
NOW HAVING TO GO OUT OF STATE.
BUT NOW THERE'S MORE OPPORTUNITY.
THE UC AND CSU AND HOPEFULLY.
THEY'RE GOING TO STAY HERE AND
BE PART OF OUR GREAT ECONOMY.
PEOPLE LIVING IN POVERTY.
I KNOW WE DON'T LIKE TALKING
ABOUT.
DO THEY NEED MORE HELP YES.
BUT THIS IS OUR CHANCE TO GIVE
THEM WHAT WE CAN.
IN ALL THE AREAS THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT INVESTING WITH ITS
EDUCATION HEALTHCARE THE
ENVIRONMENT.
ALL THE DIFFERENT SOCIAL
SERVICES HEALTH CARE.
WOULD WE LOVE TO DO MORE
ABSOLUTELY.
ABSOLUTELY EVERY DAY.
IN BUDGET COMMITTEE WE HEAR
PEOPLE I HAVE NEVER HAD A BUDGET
MEETING WHERE THEY SAID THANK
YOU WE GOT TOO MUCH THIS YEAR.
HERE'S MONEY BACK.
NOT ONE I'M STILL WAITING FOR
THAT MEETING AFTER FOUR YEARS.
SO IF YOU WANT TO GIVE IT TO ME.
COME TO ME WITH ME TO SAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH THIS GROUP GOT TOO
MUCH MONEY.
HERE'S A MONEY BACK.
THIS IS A GREAT BUDGET THAT WE
CAN ALL BE PROUD.
WHAT WE LOVE TO DO MORE
ABSOLUTELY?
AND I THINK ABOUT THAT WHEN I
DROP OFF MY KIDS TO SCHOOL EVERY
DAY.
BECAUSE I SEE IT IN THE
CLASSROOMS.
BOB THIS IS A GREAT INVESTMENT
IN OUR CHILDREN.
AND OUR FAMILIES THERE ARE
SENIORS IN REALLY THOSE PEOPLE
WHO NEED THE MOST HELP.
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE FOR AB.
SEVENTY FOUR THANK YOU MISTER
TANK AND WITHOUT THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WELL.
LOW'S A ROLL AND TALLY THE VOTE
AYE AYES SIXTY KNOWS FIFTEEN
THAT CONFERENCE REPORT IS
ADOPTED
.
MEMBERS WERE MARIA VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
AS A MEMBER WHICH REMOVE AN ITEM
FROM THE CONSENT SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FORTY NINE BY SENATOR DODD AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO ELDER
INDEPENDENT UNTIL OF THESE
AWARENESS MONTH.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE IN
THE TOWN -- ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS. TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
HOWEVER SWEATERS OUT OF CLERK
WELL [inaudible] ZERO IN TALLY
THE VOTE.
I SEVENTY SEVEN NO ZERO CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED THE CLERK
WILL READ THE REMAINING ITEMS ON
CONSENT.
SENATE RESOLUTION. FORTY THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN I SEVEN SEVEN NO
ZERO AND SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION.
FIFTY FIVE I SEVENTY SEVEN NO.
ZERO MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SEVEN I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE REFER ITEM
FOURTEEN A. B. TWO SEVENTEEN YOU
GARCIA TO REVENUE TAXATION
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE REQUEST IS
GRANTED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I MOVE
TO SUSPEND JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO
A THE PHAM NOTICE PRIMATOLOGIST
TEXAS COMMITTED HERE AB TWO
SEVENTY OR C. AT THE MONEY
HEARING A HEARING ON MONDAY JUNE
SEVENTEENTH.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SORRY MR FLOOR FOR WHAT SERVICES
WE OBJECT US FOR ROLL CALL VOTE.
MR FLOOR IS WITHHOLDING.
ON THE RULES SUSPENSION.
THIS PROCEDURAL VOTE MEMBERS
MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND MR
BONTA SECONDS.
ON THE ROLL SUSPENSION CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE OF MISS
WALDRON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE MISTER FLORA NO MISTER.
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN I. AND
MISTER FLORA NO.
TAKES FORTY ON THE WHEEL
SUSPENSION [inaudible]
CLARK.
WELL CLOSE THE ROLL EYES FIFTY
EIGHT NO SEVENTEEN THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED MISTER CALDERON YOUR
GET RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND FINALLY PURSUANT TO
ASSEMBLY RULE -- NINETY SIX I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE
REFER SB TWO THIRTY SEVEN
HERTZBERG FROM ACCOUNTABILITY
MINISTRY REVIEW COMMITTEE TO
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND
THEN BACK TO THE COUNT ABILITY
AND MINISTER AND ADMINISTRATION
REVIEW COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION I REQUEST IS
GRANTED [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
OKAY NOW SPENT BUDGET COMMITTEE
WILL BE MEETING UPON A GERMAN.
IN ROOM.
FORTY TWO OH TWO BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND FORTY TWO A TWO IN
CHIO.
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION WILL
BE MEETING.
UPON A GERMAN A ROOM
.
FOR THIRTY SEVEN THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS FRIDAY
JUNE THIRTEENTH NO FLOOR SESSION
NO CHECK IN SESSION MONDAY JUNE
SEVENTEENTH FLOOR SESSION IS AT
ONE PM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED TO RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING A FOR THE
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
SURE BONTA MOVES.
AND MISTER GALLAGHER SECONDS.
THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL MONDAY JUNE SEVENTEENTH AT
ONE PM IN THE QUORUM CALLS
LIFTED